let's talk about Jill Stein a little bit
most people who are watching this
program are listening to this program
regularly know that I am NOT a big fan
of jill stein they know that I've been
super critical of jill stein she is way
out there on science related stuff she
has what I consider a completely silly
position on Israel I don't believe she
is remotely qualified to be President of
the United States but but when I see an
unfair critique I have to point it out
and there is a really really ridiculous
critique of jill stein that surfaced
over the last few days The Daily Beast
put out an article saying hey guys Jill
Stein rails against companies that harm
the environment and Big Pharma she rails
against defense contractors in Wall
Street but she's investing in those
companies and I thought okay this could
be interesting let's take a look at it
and I looked into it and it turns out
that Jill Stein invests in index funds
which hold hundreds or sometimes
thousands of companies in their
portfolio they follow large groups of
the economy sometimes as big as the
entire economy so what's the big
critique well for example Jill Stein has
somewhere between one and two million
dollars invested in mutual funds like
the Vanguard 500 fund I've spoken about
this before I have money invested in
that fund this is one of if not the most
one of the most heavily invested funds
through Vanguard which I've said many
times I use because it has really really
low management fees sometimes hedge
funds will charge one two even three
percent a year right these vanguard
funds charge between point 05 and point
two percent and all it does is track the
S&P 500 now by virtue of that there's
going to be all sorts of companies
included in that because those companies
are part of the economy Stein has
invested somewhere between one and two
and a half million dollars in funds like
the tiaa-cref equity index which holds
investments in stocks like JP Morgan
Chase Citigroup Deutsche Bank the ones
that she really heavily opposes on Wall
Street it's a really broad fund managed
by t.i
a craft which runs retirement accounts
for people that work in academia or
research or medical and cultural fields
I've spoken about this many times I
don't think that investing in individual
stocks is particularly wise over the
long term very few people will actually
do better than the market averages and
over the very long term there are very
few hedge fund managers and expensive
money managers that will actually beat
the market averages the most prudent way
to invest is in the broadest based of of
stocks possible over the longest
possible period of time at the lowest
possible cost and that Vanguard 500 fund
they have they also have one that is
called the total stock market index fund
which basically invest in the entire
United States stock market all stocks
their fees are super cheap if anything
Pat and you know I'm not a fan of Jill
Stein this improves my opinion of her
that instead of of falling prey to
expensive money managers or head hedge
funds she knows or at least she's doing
what indicates that she knows that the
most prudent way to invest is in these
super low cost broad funds she's not
directly investing in or supporting acts
on any more than I am by holding this
fun I think this is a totally bogus
critique of jill stein right in the
truth is about 50 million Americans have
investments in mutual funds and index
funds and they all those on mobile oh no
of course not you've no saying how the
money's managed yeah and also the Daily
Beast is run by iac/interactivecorp they
did a whole hit piece on her as sort of
a conflict into a venture story yeah
meanwhile on the board of that company
is Chelsea Clinton yeah and that's I
mean but of course people probably
probably would be less surprised that
the Clintons are invested in many of
these funds and and I guess the idea is
look at what Jill Stein says and look at
what she does as Pat said 50 million
Americans are invested in in of these
funds very often you don't even have a
choice if you want a retirement account
at all from your work and you want them
to do matching for example you might get
to choose between four or five funds all
of which to some degree invest in these
companies completely bogus smear attempt
and the saddest part is
it's not just the Daily Beast which is
Pat pointed out has some interesting of
ownership ties some left-wing blogs have
also fallen for this supposed
progressive blogs there is plenty to
critique about Jill Stein that you don't
need to go into she's against oil
companies but owns index funds it is a
totally flaccid and ridiculous critique
and I wish the left wouldn't fall for it